Let's try our hand at another unfrosted cake problem. If 1/6 of a cake is
frosted with strawberry icing and 3/8 is frosted with blueberry icing, what
fraction of cake is not frosted? To set up this problem, let's give ourselves a
picture of what's going on. Here are two rectangular cakes and I have 1/6 of it
frosted in strawberry icing. For this other cake, I'm going to frost 3/8 of it
in blueberry icing. Notice I've split up the cake into 8 equal parts and I have
3 of those 8 frosted or 3/8. I'm not working with two cakes though, I'm working
with one cake. So, let's visualize these two cakes on one. I'm going to show
that here. So, notice I have 1/6 of the cake frosted in strawberry icing and 3/8
of it frosted in blueberry icing. And we're trying to figure out what fraction
is not frosted. The chocolate part. To set up this problem, we know we're going
to start with one whole cake. Then, I need to subtract off 1/6 of the cake and
3/8 of the cake. So, I have 1 minus 1/6 minus 3/8. I can compare sixth to
eighths right now, they are different size pieces so I can't just subtract these
numbers. I need to get a common denominator, just like we did when adding
fractions. So, let's try this with a quiz and see if we can remember how to find
the common denominator. What do you think the common denominator would be for
these fractions? Remember, you can list the multiples or use the factor tree.
You don't have to worry about the one when finding the common denominator. This
is because we can change the 1 into 2/2, 3/3, 12/12, or even a 107/107. All of
these numbers are still equal to one. So, what's the common denominator for
these fractions? You can put your answers in this box here. Remember, to find
the common demominator, you can list the multiples or use the factor tree.